vous voulez vraiment où le plus loin
jean baptiste quand on arrive plein air
et pose les plots à ma pause les plots
toi tu as les ballons on dirait que tu
les mets dedans dans le sang et du coup
comme c'est nous qui avons les ballons
c'est toi qui va faire la première phase
j'ai tout blanc voit et on lance le
match plus d'effet
[Musique]
ce matin
il
[Musique]
petit à petit on est recouvert de ce
sang qui symbolise en fait les milliers
de morts qu il y a eu sur les chantiers
de port de la coupe du monde
[Musique]
oh
m
on peut imaginer que c'est comme si vous
vouliez une maison avec des amis vous
êtes 10 vous savez qu'à 60 ouvriers qui
sont morts pour la construire parce que
vous vous devez vraiment partir en
vacances dans cette maison de vacances
je suis passé sur bamako du monde du
qatar c'est un peu pareil
[Musique]
il ya aussi un enjeu de
responsabilisation des joueurs c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est déguisé en joueurs
et qu'on voulait vraiment jouer ce match
parce qu'on pense que les joueurs ont
une responsabilité en tant qu'équipe à
la fois individuel on sait l'impact que
leurs actions peuvent avoir
[Musique]